und wir wollen gleich weiter sprechen
über die Situation in der Ostukraine und
ihre politischen und militärischen
Konsequenzen jetzt mit Generalleutnant
Markus Laubenthal er ist der
stellvertretende Generalinspektor der
Bundeswehr da ist er guten Morgen also
der zweitranghöchste Soldat der
Bundeswehr herzlich willkommen zum ZDF
Morgenmagazin guten Morgen wie bewerten
Sie die derzeitige Lage in der
Ostukraine glauben Sie die ukrainische
Armee hat eine Chance die russische
Offensive abzuwehren
nun wir haben in der Vergangenheit in
den letzten sieben Wochen gesehen dass
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte sehr klug
verteidigen sie kennen ihren Raum sie
sind höchst motiviert sie verteidigen
ihr Land die bisherigen Kriegsziele
hatte Russland nicht erreicht die
Einnahme die rasche Einnahme der
Hauptstadt Kiew und damit die Übernahme
der Regierung und dann auch vielleicht
die Hoffnung auf ein schnelles Ende hat
sich nicht erfüllt der Widerstandswillen
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung ist ungebrochen
ist hoch es wird jetzt darauf ankommen
jetzt im Don buns in einem völlig
anderen Geländeteil für die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte natürlich dieses Land zu
behaupten sich aber zugleich der eigenen
Vernichtung zu entziehen wenn man jetzt
darüber nachdenkt welche Art von Waffen
die Ukrainer jetzt brauchen muss ja
vorher erstmal muss man wissen was für
eine Art Krieg dort im Osten jetzt
geführt wird ich frage jetzt mal Air
laienhaft ist es eher ein Krieg in der
großen Fläche also Panzer gegen Panzer
auf weitem Feld oder sprechen wir eher
von Häuser kämpfen wo Straße um Straße
und Ort
dort erobert oder verteidigt werden muss
nun im Vergleich zu dem was wir in den
ersten Wochen gesehen haben ist der
Geländeteil deutlich offener es
ermöglicht also dass mechanisierte
Gefecht das heißt das Zusammenwirken von
Kampfpanzern und Schützenpanzern im
Verbund mit der Artillerie also
indirekten Feuer was die Voraussetzungen
dann auch für den Einsatz dieser Systeme
schafft das war vorher in den engeren
Bereichen in Richtung der Hauptstadt
Kiew da wo sehr stark kanalisiert wurde
da wo auch aufgrund der
Geländebedingungen man vorrangig auf
Straßen angewiesen war das ist eine
völlig andere Charakteristik es ist also
durchaus davon auszugehen dass hier eher
Raum greifen da auf größerer Breite und
dann auch mit schnellen Stößen in die
Tiefe versucht werden kann Gelände zu
gewinnen und zu nehmen heißt ja wenn ich
das richtig verstehe umso mehr geht es
dann jetzt um schwere Waffen und damit
sind wir natürlich bei dem Stichwort
dieser Tage in der politischen
Diskussion der Bundeskanzler hat gestern
erklärt er will nicht direkt deutsche
Panzer zum Beispiel in der Ukraine
liefern aber er will die Lieferung
schwerer Waffen von der Industrie mit
viel Geld unterstützen Grund die
Bundeswehr habe gar keine schweren
Waffen übrig die sie also derzeit nicht
brauche und daher nicht liefern können
stimmt das ja man muss sehen dass die
Bundeswehr natürlich in vielfältigen
Verpflichtungen gebunden ist wir sind
für die NATO in einem circa dreijährigen
Auftrag für die schnellen Eingreifkräfte
wir stellen weit über 13.000 Soldaten
das wird sich im nächsten Jahr wo wir
noch mehr Verantwortung übernehmen auch
noch mal erhöhen in diesen dann etwa
16.000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten stecken
genau die Fähigkeiten die hier auch in
Rede stehen es sind unsere Kampfpanzer
sind unsere Schützenpanzer sowohl der
neue Puma aber der zunächst mit einem
Verband auch der Maler ist noch dort
drin und vor allen Dingen die Arterie um
diesen um diese Streitmacht aufrecht zu
halten zu betreiben und auch folgekräfte
rechtzeitig auszubilden brauchen wir
diese Waffensysteme und sie wissen ja
über die Berichterstattung der der
letzten Jahre über den zus der
Bundeswehr und das ist ja auch der Grund
warum wir dieses Sondervermögen brauchen
damit wir genau diese Defizite
beseitigen und auch die Lücken die
materiellen Lücken die über die Jahre
geschlagen wurden das finde ich auch
wieder schließen kann ich möchte noch
mal konkret nachfragen sie haben die
Marder Schützenpanzer angesprochen der
ukrainische Botschafter ist ja jetzt
viel in den Medien seit Wochen manchmal
nicht sehr diplomatisch vergreift sich
auch mal im Ton aber gestern hat er
unter anderem im heute journal sehr
konkrete Zahlen genannt und argumentiert
die Bundeswehr sagt er habe rund 400
Marder Schützenpanzer davon würden etwa
100 für Ausbildungen Training benutzt
also kein Einsatz Ausbildung und
Training diese 100 könnte so sagt er die
Bundeswehr sofort an die Ukraine
übergeben und später ersetzen wie sehen
Sie das dazu muss man zwei Dinge sagen
zum einen kann man diese 100 nicht
einfach übergeben weil dann hätte die
Bundeswehr nichts mehr um Kräfte
entsprechend nachzu
nachzuschicken wenn die wenn die NRF
Unterstützung braucht wir hätten keine
Möglichkeit mehr uns an solchen Dingen
zu beteiligen wie jetzt der Battlegroup
in der Slowakei die wir gerade aussetzen
und der tschechischer Führung wir hätten
keine Möglichkeit mehr auf
Eventualitäten zu reagieren und das für
die die Verteidigungsfähigkeit doch
erheblich schwächen zum zweiten muss man
sagen dass dieses Waffensystem Maler
eben ein System ist es muss in der
Gesamtheit also mit den Lenkraketen die
dazugehören mit den entsprechenden
Handwaffen mit der dazugehörigen
Munition für die Maschinenkanone
versorgbar sein und es muss technisch
kriegstauglich eingesetzt werden können
und das setzt eine gewisse Ausbildung
voraus jetzt ist also nicht so dass der
der den Maler kennt oder irgendeinen
Schützenpanzer kennt dann diese
Fahrzeuge auch bedienen kann bzw jedes
andere bedienen kann ich denke davon
sind wir weit entfernt sondern das
bedarf einer gewissen gründlichen
Vorbereitung das muss man seriös angehen
und das glaube ich ist das entscheidende
wenn man damit erfolgreich kämpfen will
gibt es ja aber auch wie gesagt ich sage
es eher leihenhaft Schnellkurse bei den
Amerikanern da wird sehr schnell
ausgebildet sie haben die Ausbildung an
den deutschen Waffen angesprochen das
nicht eine sehr deutsche Sicht der
ukrainische Verteidigungsminister sagt
unsere Soldaten können alle Panzer
fahren also muss man in so eine
Ausnahmesituation nicht auch ja
schneller sein
ich glaube man kann schnell sein aber
dennoch ist es immer noch eine Frage von
Wochen und zum zweiten muss dieses Gerät
ja auch hergerichtet werden und es muss
versorgbar werden ein Großteil der Maler
wird ja auch herangezogen um die
entsprechenden Ersatzteile
bereitzustellen das heißt wir bedienen
und sozusagen aus der Flotte damit wir
den Teil den wir dann wirklich einsetzen
in unseren nato-verpflichtungen und an
der Ostflanke der NATO zur Zeit damit
wir die noch betreiben können also keine
schweren Waffen keine mörderpanzer von
Seiten der Bundeswehr weil sie gebraucht
werden das waren Einschätzungen vom
stellvertretenden Generalinspektor der
Bundeswehr Generalleutnant Markus
Laubenthal vielen Dank